Welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going
to be my new thor 4 guardians of the galaxy 3
video marvel made a couple big announcements in
the past week about how everything's going to
work with the big crossovers so we'll break it
all down there's a whole bunch of easter eggs
a lot of these characters will also be coming
back in avengers 5 eventually so i'll explain
what's going on with that too if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the videos
we'll do a new amazon giveaway too all you have
to do to enter is be a subscriber and let me know
which other big characters and movies you want
to see thor cross over into during marvel phase
4 and marvel phase 5. thankfully chris hemsworth
said that he's sticking around for the long haul
all the way through avengers 5 which obviously
isn't going to happen for a couple years now
chris pratt also said that he wants
to stick around for a long time too
but just starting with the big stuff first
if you didn't see it recently marvel just
announced how the thor 4 guardians of the galaxy 3
crossover scenes in the stories are going to work
right after avengers end game we'd heard
that some version of a crossover between thor
and the guardians of the galaxy in guardians 3
and thor 4 would happen we just didn't know which
characters they'd be doing and what the story that
was going to be between the guardians showing up
in thor 4 and then thor showing up in guardians 3.
way back at the beginning of the year vin diesel
completely spilled the beans on everything i'm
sure he got a really nasty text from james gunn
about giving away big spoilers so tom holland
is not the only spoiler man inside the mcu
thor will also the director talk to me about how
thor will incorporate some of the guardians of the
galaxy which would be very interesting nobody
knows but maybe i shouldn't have said anything
um but i only have two words uh about that
character and it is alpha group james gunn has
also been talking more about guardians 3 recently
as well and about how everything has changed about
the marvel movies since marvel changed the order
that they're releasing everything and that kind of
messed up the original crossover story plans and
their post-credit scene plans normally everything
gets released in a certain order and they have
certain post-credit scenes the tease the next
movie kevin feige also said something similar in
a recent interview separately for the black widow
movie yes we've changed the order of all the
marvel phase 4 movies but we've had to make a
few minor changes so that nothing gets spoiled or
revealed before it's ready to be revealed you may
have noticed recently that marvel just started
making more noise about all the stuff that's
coming up in the past month because wandavision
is getting ready to be released and thankfully
they finally revealed when they're actually
releasing wandavision episode so i'll explain
that stuff at the end of the video too thankfully
there's a really big disney investor meeting
happening december 10th where they're going to
be releasing a lot of footage and previews of
all their upcoming programming that includes the
marvel movies and the marvel disney plus series
but number four per marvel's announcement the
only guardians of the galaxy 3 characters that
have been confirmed for thor 4 are chris pratt
and vin diesel star-lord and groot or tree as
thor calls him this kind of gives you an idea of
where this is happening in the timeline between
avengers and games ending that thor asgardians of
the galaxy scene and what's going on with the plot
of thor 4 separately from the plot of guardians
of the galaxy 3 because per that scene most of
the beginning of guardians 3 is then going to find
that other version of gamora that came forward in
the timeline from 2014. the one that did not have
the relationship with star-lord so he's going to
try and find her and bring her back into the
family so to speak originally guardians of the
galaxy 3 was supposed to be released summer 2020
so had things gone down according to plan we would
have already seen that movie so originally the
crossover plan is that thor would have showed up
at the beginning of guardians 3 then gone back
to earth instead now thor 4 is happening first
so they had to switch things kind of rewrite the
scene and now the guardians are showing up at the
beginning of thor 4. the reason why everyone was
making so much noise about this during the past
week is because chris pratt and vin diesel both
just showed up in australia at the set of the thor
4 movie to film their scenes or in vin diesel's
case do the voice over for their scenes because
they use body doubles and special effects to do
teenage group when they're filming on set most of
the main cast of thor 4 chris hemsworth natalie
portman taika watiti all started doing their
script read-throughs in the past couple of weeks
so that's why i say the guardians are showing up
at the beginning of thor 4 because they're just
getting ready to start shooting the movie right
now also really cool star wars detail if you've
been watching my star wars mandalorian season 2
videos this past season so far the technology that
they used to film that with the really cool led
walls to sort of map the backgrounds while the
actors are walking around they're actually using
a giant super-sized version of that to do a lot
of the thor 4 scenes but just in terms of where
this is happening in the timeline at the beginning
of thor 4 with the exception of the giant 5-year
time jump in avengers end game most of the marvel
movies timeline of movies moves at the same pace
is real lifetime so for instance avengers
end game ended summer 2023 thor 4 is coming
out a couple years after avengers end game so
a couple years will probably have gone by when
thor 4 is picking up giving thor time to lose
all that weight which will make you guys happy
taika waititi actually did a live stream a while
ago earlier this year people asked him will there
be fat thor during thor 4. he pretty much said
that that joke had been played out so they weren't
planning on doubling down on fat thor a whole
bunch so maybe they'll have some jokes at the
beginning of the movie about him losing the weight
and star-lord's bowflex just to call back to the
jokes from avengers infinity war with thor and
the guardians but for the most part thor will go
back to being the version of thor that you know
him as even though he will get a different look
during the film like each new thor movie he gets a
slightly different costume slightly different look
for the most part he'll look like you expect him
to look christian bale also just showed up in
australia on the set of thor 4. he's going to be
their main villain obviously he's still a mystery
character though there are a lot of really good
solid theories and rumors he's supposed to be a
space-based villain from somewhere else so that
kind of tells you why it's relevant that thor is
still with the guardians at the beginning of thor
4. he still has stormbreaker he can still open the
bifrost any time he wants allowing him to fast
travel all over the universe so he's not really
traveling with them just because he needs a ride
like he says that at the end of avengers end game
he's mostly traveling with them just for fun for
the adventure of it because they're his friends
but it makes sense he's with them at the beginning
of thor 4 getting into all kinds of trouble in
deep space when he learns about the threat of
christian bale's villain that provides him with
the need to go back to new asgard on earth also
thinking about this in a multiverse sense because
multiverse is such a big story trope during marvel
phase four taika watiti also confirmed that loki
would be in the movie because he said it'd be
weird to do a thor movie without a version of
loki but is going to be the multiverse loki
from avengers end game in the loki series
showing up in this reality he'll probably also
have something to do with thor's reason for coming
back to planet earth because the loki series
is literally loki traveling throughout earth's
history messing with major events even though when
he's doing this he's kind of in multiple alternate
realities and they're doing multiple versions of
loki from the comics like you have the main loki
that looks like tom hiddleston then you have kid
loki you have female loki you have old man loki
they're going to get really crazy with the loki
series don't worry it's premiering during 2021
i'll mention that in a second again too but that
explains why loki is near planet earth during the
events of thor 4 because most of the series will
take place on different versions of earth he can
also help explain some of the bigger twists like
jane foster wielding a version of mjolnir because
either they have to get one from an alternate
universe because hella destroyed the original one
or they have to get the dwarves to forge a new one
or they have to get them to reforge the old one
i think it's just a little more exciting if
multiverse is such a big deal during marvel phase
four if you just get a mjolnir from an alternate
reality but also you have to remember thinking
about the multiverse doctor strange 2 multiverse
of madness is literally being released one month
after thor 4 comes out in theaters so we might
wind up with another doctor strange thor crossover
scene sort of calling back to the jokes from their
crossover in thor ragnarok in the original doctor
strange movie you just have to imagine a version
of this scene where this is the alternate reality
version of loki going through another version of
this trying to have a standoff with doctor strange
and still getting his ass handed to him i have
been falling for 30 minutes but just talking about
marvel phase 4 story progression in the multiverse
because that's such a big deal you have more
and more alternate reality versions of avengers
characters showing up in the marvel phase 4 movies
and disney plus series all starting with the
wandavision episodes so wandavision is really the
beginning of explaining all these big story twists
so it not only is it really important to marvel
phase 4 it's just going to be super cool series in
general marvel finally confirmed that wandavision
is going to be released january 15 2021 just a
small couple weeks delay the mandalorian season
2 finale is going to air december 18th so really
it's not that long before wandavision starts
the loki series is still on track to be released
during 2021 after falcon and winter soldier but
you have morbius being released in march falcon
and winter soldier probably being released
sometime right after wandavision within a couple
weeks then you have the black widow movie in may
venom 2 in june shang chi in july marvel's what
if series is also still supposed to be released
at some point during the summer maybe late summer
the eternals movie is in november spider-man 3 is
in december then right after that thor 4 is being
released in february 2022 then like i said one
month after that in march dr strange 2 is coming
out but everyone let me know in the comments
if thor is going to continue to be sort of this
bridge between the cosmic stuff in the earth-based
stuff in marvel phase 4 marvel phase 5 which other
big movies and characters do you want to see him
cross over into i know everyone would love to
see a silver surfer thor crossover sometime
during marvel phase 5 so hopefully he'll show
up at some point during the fantastic four movie
but while you wait for everything everyone click
here for my full star wars mandalorian season
2 episode 3 video and click here for that thor 4
teaser that taikawatidi released earlier this year
thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!